so what's it like having your boy have a
relationship that's all over the news is
that like weird
well yeah it's it's weird matt damon
reacts to his buddy ben affleck's
rekindled romance with jennifer lopez
that got me really excited the 50 year
old actor sat down with showtime's
dieses and
mero on thursday to promote his new
movie stillwater
and when the hosts asked matt about his
bff's highly publicized relationship
he had this to say i have to say you
know the press was particularly terrible
to them like 18 years ago
so what's nice is that it's very nice
at least they're being nice this time
around of course the two
famously known as benifer recently
rekindled their romance
17 years after they called it quits the
two first started dating back in 2002
while starring in their first movie
together
jilly i'm sorry do we know each other
not yet they quickly got engaged but by
2003 they called off their wedding just
days before their planned september
ceremony and they officially split
in january 2004 it was my first like
adult heartbreak
we were about to get married it didn't
work out and it was just
a bad heartbreak like you know just one
of those breakups that really
you know it was like a tough one for me
well the two
are very much back on and a source
recently told et
quote they have insane on another level
chemistry they are both
super passionate and are head over heels
with each other
just like they once were this time
around however
they both really feel like this is it
yeah that seems pretty clear since jlo
has been blowing up our instafeed with
sexy snaps from their lovers getaway in
europe
a topic matt playfully addressed with
e.t at the stillwater premiere
there's a lot going on in france right
now did you call ben up and say what
gives man why didn't you give me an
invite
no i think that's a private trip i don't
think i'd be invited on that one i might
be a bit of a third wheel
and while the two might be on a romantic
getaway for two
matt said ben is never too busy to
answer his texts
they're on vacation right now but he
still responded when i hit him up about
the red sox
no you still have priorities still right
there all right he hasn't lost
the power never